let's play one more one more win lose or
draw and that will be and I play play
okay I was hoping for a staff for
gambits but wait no six this game I'll
play a bit of us will end with some kind
of cabins we might have three I'll
insist I insist that you accept was like
a night's tango with E 5 so Bishop f4 is
like the standard move here it's
probably a better version of the blue
house for whites but Bishop f4 there's
g5 okay so we're gonna get some typical
through the pests I should have played
this first plan anyway
we're reaching a position I've had many
times before ideas just eventually tech
meets the bishop on the fates rookie
aide is a reason the reason for rakia is
eventually Bishop f8 in this case now I
just swing over I'm trying to have some
fun play lab d6 unleashing the bishop
idea the idea Queen h4 and eventually
sacking actually interesting rook h4
yeah I won't let me draw an arrow from a
to H four-foot the rook eventually found
its way to the Kings side the pawns
pinned Queen off six doesn't work you
just like Bishop d7 for b6 I want a
fiend keto it's a weird position it's
hard to exploit the rook here ideas to
play Queen e7 and take the pawn very
tempted to suck on h3 now which actually
looks kind of fun yeah it works for my
opponent the previous game sacking a
minor piece for dubious compensation but
there might be real compensation hearing
because Queen each Wars coming and I got
five that's a bold move
finding maybe nine of three another son
who did UNK thanks for subbing now I'm
ready to to lift the other rook as well
these pieces seem kind of clumsy I'm
just using the strategy where I I get
initiative at the cost of dubious play
and then my opponent is the one who's
thinking so maybe I'll pay off and the
bishop does a crucial job defending g7 I
mean this weird moved to Queen eight
it's actually kind of clever play Queen
eh is for the show yeah why not
it's a funny move threatening me than
two if this I assume that's some
concession maybe Oh actually if before I
just take and then Queen Queen each one
still a threat - wait how does the white
deal with Queen each one there's Queen
eh isn't winning on the spot because
there's no way to the king of - there's
Queen G - means in spite just be winning
well the move Queen aids
so weights gonna try and run but why
can't you know I can't run and can't
hide in each one here in me never spent
my money any better than this
oh hey coffin season thanks so much at
first I thought that said coffin season
what's a coffin like a muffin inside the
coffin or a puffin I don't know
thanks for the sub though a point
opponent Flags yeah so Queenie that was
a nice move hello you two yeah maybe
I'll put that on youtube I was a
youtuber the game Queen aids using bore
geometry so what happened there so my
rook so the rook went from so I guess in
this position there went from here to
here to here and the Queen went from
here to here
decent thumb now pay it's anglo-saxon
thanks for subbing yeah on YouTube you
can subscribe for free oh there's a
button below the video yeah thanks
people for watching and for YouTube
people I'll see you in the future